[Música]
sí
los insumos que van entonces aumentar
los costos de producción y bueno y
también van a disminuir el poder de
compra de la gente la gente se va a dar
con cuenta de estos momento dado y va a
pedir entonces un reajuste de sueldo
lo que la mayoría de los asalariados
reivindican es tener un salario fijo que
aumente algo que sirve para la
jubilación para hacer un crédito cosas
así
bienvenidos a una nueva edición de
francia- enfoco en los últimos meses los
precios han ido en aumento en francia
según el inss el instituto nacional de
estadística y estudios económicos la
inflación alcanzó un récord de 36 por
ciento en un año un nivel que no se veía
desde hace tres décadas esto puede
deberse a la reanudación de las
actividades después de dos años de
pandemia y al alza de los precios de la
energía agravada ahora por la guerra en
ucrania
un ejemplo claro de la inflación es el
precio de los combustibles que no para
de subir el país también vive la
aceleración del precio de los servicios
de los productos manufacturados y
también de los alimentos en el siguiente
informe les contamos como los franceses
se están preparando para enfrentar estos
aumentos calor y roba trabaja en la
administración universitaria en la
ciudad de puente en el oeste del país
forma parte de los franceses que se
levantan temprano para tomar el tren
desde que los precios se dispararon en
las estaciones de gasolina su vehículo
se queda en el garaje se trató de la
gasolina del desgaste del vehículo
cuando tenemos más de 50 kilómetros por
recorrer creo que está claro en la
ciudad de leh en el norte de francia se
reparten tarjetas de 30 euros para
ayudar a pagar la gasolina una medida
apreciada por los habitantes es caro yo
soy una empleada doméstica así que pongo
mucha gasolina cada mes más de 200 euros
nos van a hacer bien sin condiciones la
alcaldía ha desbloqueado está
financiación por unanimidad nos ha
costado 1.500 euros al municipio eso
representa un poco más del 1 por ciento
de nuestro presupuesto operativo pero
hace dos años que no hacemos eventos así
que este presupuesto podría utilizarse
para otros fines en este restaurante de
dordoña en el suroeste de francia el
jefe ha optado por dar una prima a sus
empleados además de la prima la
inflación prometida por el gobierno a 38
millones de franceses son muchas cosas
cambia el doble es muy simple cuando
usted paga 100 euros de salario
suplementario paga 100 euros de
impuestos suplementarios house terremoto
por eso la cuestión de los salarios es
crucial cerca de burdeos en el suroeste
del país estos obreros están en huelga
los últimos aumentos donde sólo el 18
por ciento para los obreros es decir 32
euros netos por mes
lo que la mayoría de los asalariados
reivindican es tener un salario fijo que
aumente algo que sirve para la
jubilación para hacer un crédito cosas
así y descansar en 2022 los salarios
podrían aumentar de un 2 a un 3 por
ciento pero no es seguro que esto sea
suficiente para paliar la inflación
nos acompaña a gabriel jiménez rochel es
doctor en economía y profesor de
macroeconomía en neumas business y
profesor gracias por estar con nosotros
en france24 muchísimas gracias profesor
es una mala noticia para los hogares
franceses esta alza de los precios que
puede pasar con la energía con el gas
con el petróleo y ahora ampliado por la
situación de lo que está ocurriendo en
ucrania si bueno por el momento hasta
antes de la guerra la situación era tan
mala francia era el país que tenía menos
inflación
en toda la unión europea en toda la zona
euro sin embargo esa inflación se está
acumulando está aumentando un poco ya y
ahora con la guerra efectivamente ese
cúmulo de precios puede aumentar aún más
y puede ser más persistente pero
quisiera explicar primero una cosa que
es la inflación el problema de la
inflación la inflación de precios es
siempre una consecuencia de la cantidad
de moneda en circulación en la economía
o sea que durante el periodo del cobi en
varios países la zona euro estados
unidos-japón
inyectaron moneda para poder sostener la
economía durante ese periodo de
inactividad y de recuperación el
problema entonces es como ese dinero va
a circular en la economía cómo va a ser
redistribuido
y ahí entonces tenemos el problema el
problema de los vectores de precios de
vectores de inflación que suena el
petróleo el gas la energía en general y
bueno los bienes commodities las
materias primas primeras y eso es lo que
bueno como la influencia es exactamente
bueno son los insumos que van entonces
aumentar los costos de producción y
bueno y también van a disminuir el poder
de compra de la gente la gente se va a
dar cuenta de esto un momento dado y va
a pedir entonces un reajuste de sueldos
a inicios de este año el primer ministro
anunció ayudas para los franceses sobre
todo para aquellos que tienen largos
kilómetros de desplazamiento y también
ayudas en el pago de las facturas
realmente las ayudas son suficientes
para lo que está pasando y para lo que
se viene pero después depende de cada
hogar pero normalmente esto son vectores
de inflación o sea es dinero que va a
estar siendo orientado y que va a
aumentar también el poder de compra
monetario de esta gente o sea que ellos
van a poder pagar las cuentas pero al
pagar las cuentas van a validar el alza
de precios entonces el dinero vuelve a
circular y esto va a sostener la
inflación en realidad o sea que les va a
ayudar en un primer momento pero bueno a
la medida que el dinero circule esto va
a sostener la inflación no no le va a
eliminar no o sea es algo solamente
temporario el costo de vida también se
empieza a sentir en los alimentos en los
productos manufacturados puede generar
esto una incertidumbre para el francés
de la pgje para su bolsillo bueno por el
momento antes de la situación actual en
el este de europa y tanto porque bueno
era una recuperación económica que tenía
lugar nuevo que había lugar o sea
durante dos años de kobe el mundo
prácticamente paró se rompieron las
cadenas de logística de distribución de
mercancías y muchas fábricas pararon
sobre todo en china no
y ahora con la recuperación bueno los
pedidos vuelven y vuelven en masa y
sobre todo sostenidos por mucho dinero
que fue inyectado en la economía
entonces es mucho dinero que viene de
sopetón muy rápido paro men y que bueno
aumentan los precios de los insumos de
los productos y eso a medida que la
logística mundial se iba recuperando los
precios bueno tendrían que ir
estabilizándose pero bueno ahora con la
guerra hay mucha incertidumbre con todo
esto y no hay que olvidar que en
situación bueno de guerra o bueno
nosotros aquí en europa occidental más
de apoyo a un posible aliado nuestro
problema es más que que vamos a usar más
política monetaria o sea más dinero más
inflación para poder sostener la
economía y existe alguna manera para
contener esa alza en los precios la
única manera normalmente la manera más
cruda evidente es
parar con la inyección monetaria pero
bueno esto también sería parar de
sostener la economía real o sea que por
el momento no es una alternativa viable
en la economía mundial porque son
muchísimas gracias por estar en france
24 muchísimas gracias
[Música]
ante el aumento de la inflación el poder
adquisitivo es ahora un tema prioritario
para los franceses y es tema además
esencial en la campaña presidencial que
está incluso justamente desde nuestro
último episodio de francia en poco hemos
venido mostrándole los perfiles de los
candidatos al elíseo hoy hablamos de la
candidata socialista anne hidalgo
la alcaldesa de parís está entre un 2 y
un 3% en intención de voto y se ubica en
un noveno puesto según los sondeos les
contamos quién es y cuál es su propuesta
en materia económica
franco-española de 62 años la socialista
anne hidalgo es la primera mujer
alcaldesa de parís y quiere ser también
la primera presidenta de francia llegó
al país cuando tenía dos años hija de
inmigrantes socialistas y un abuelo
castigado por el franquismo a los 14
años obtuvo la doble nacionalidad y se
cambió el nombre de anna a anna estudió
derecho mientras trabajaba como niñera
luego se convirtió en una inspectora
laboral desde que llegó a la alcaldía de
la capital ha liderado la revolución
verde
medidas sostenibles como el uso de la
bicicleta le han valido aplausos y
también un fuerte rechazo ha tenido que
enfrentar los atentados terroristas del
13 de noviembre de 2015 las
manifestaciones de los chalecos
amarillos la huelga en los transportes
públicos y el incendio de la catedral de
notre-dame ahora el camino al elíseo
para esta auto declarada feminista
socialdemócrata y ecologista no está
despejado está debilitada en las
encuestas a la presidencia lejos de
llegar a la primera vuelta entre su
programa de 70 propuestas promete
aumentar el salario mínimo en un 15% es
decir 200 euros netos más al mes
y lo único que sale no lo he dicho y lo
repito el nivel de los salarios en
francia es extremadamente bajo no
permite y lo vemos hoy con esta cuestión
del poder adquisitivo que nuestros
conciudadanos se alojen dignamente un
pastor y sale a su antojo ser
defensora de la unión europea y por su
historia también lo ha sido siempre de
las políticas migratorias y de asilo
como se ha visto en sus declaraciones
sobre ucrania yo pues me
propongo amigos míos que iniciemos un
procedimiento acelerado de adhesión de
ucrania a la unión europea
allí debe ser nuestra respuesta
ahora entre los principales candidatos
de esta ala no se llega ni al 20 por
ciento de los votos en total
otro de los candidatos a la presidencia
de francia es fabián es el secretario
del partido comunista francés la
expectativa en intención de voto es por
ahora de un 4% según tres firmas
encuestadoras que lo ubican además en el
séptimo puesto según los sondeos les
contamos cuál ha sido su trayectoria y
cuál es su propuesta en materia
económica
desde hace 15 años francia no tenía un
candidato comunista a la presidencia ha
sido en una familia de la misma línea
fabián hoss el de 52 años y de 21 en el
norte de francia es periodista de
formación diputado y secretario del
partido comunista francés un movimiento
que ha perdido en las últimas décadas
influencia en la política francesa entre
sus 180 propuestas se destaca el aumento
del salario mínimo
casi un alza del 20% sobre el salario
actual propone además reducir las horas
de trabajo de las 35 actuales a 32
garantizar una pensión mínima de 1.200
euros netos y una jubilación a los 60
años y no de 62 como es actualmente
quiere triplicar el impuesto de las
fortunas y nacionalizar empresas
eléctricas y grandes grupos económicos
recuperaremos el poder sobre nuestra
herramienta industrial sobre ellos obra
de jano y reubicaremos aquí en el país
la producción de nuestros vehículos
en cuanto a la guerra en ucrania condena
de la elección de las armas apoyo a la
acogida de los refugiados y las
sanciones económicas a rusia es
necesario poder desplegar un componente
de sanciones cada vez más fuerte para
poder asfixiar y cerrar a vladimir putin
y obligarlo a sentarse a la mesa de
conversaciones para un alto el fuego
incluso sobre la cuestión energética
esto plantea la cuestión de la soberanía
energética de francia y de europa the
love aboga por una reconstrucción de la
unión europea y exige la salida de
francia de la otan por ahora la
expectativa de voto para este aspirante
etiquetado en la izquierda lo dejan
lejos de estar en una primera vuelta
gracias por habernos acompañado en esta
edición de francia en foco recuerde que
puede ingresar a nuestra página web más
24 punto com para ver esta edición y
también las anteriores